reg let me tell you about a dream I had
okay okay I had a dream that I asked JJ
reddick to help me with my jump shot
number one I'll probably ask you what
did you eat before you went to bed
because they say sometimes that affects
dreams so you probably had a big old
pizza and maybe I like a brownie sundae
or something so probably in your dream
state you defaulted to JJ Redick to help
you with your jump shot as opposed to
your BFF who's on here weekly to show up
in your dream to kind of help you with
that follow through I'm I'm a little
offended but I can't fault JJ Redick
because he does have a wet jumper at
times okay do you a wet jumper do you
have you ever had a basketball dream all
the time I still have them is it dream
or nightmare
sadly they have been nightmares I think
because what's funny at 52 I think of
the 22 version of Reggie Miller but in a
52 year old body so I can't close out I
can't get around anyone and I think I'm
22 but I'm playing in my 52 year old
self body and it's not cool Daniel's not
cool at all I also have dreams they're
nightmares that I get to the set of
SportsCenter late or I'm not prepared
and I haven't done SportsCenter in 10
years well what's funny is I talk about
SportsCenter I have a dream about facing
Chicago and Michael Jordan in that
series and I replay replay but there's
certain scenarios during that series
that I have dreams about that I wish
would have occurred and then I wake up
is like why didn't we do that why didn't
I do that so yes I have dreams of that
as well I don't know why why Michael I
mean there's so many I mean why him how
would he feel if he knows that he still
gives you nightmares Wow
give me nightmares okay I have a game
okay dreams doesn't give me not even
okay he never he never nightmares
nightmares would elude that I'm afraid
and he's the boogie man he's not the
boogeyman to me is there a Jordan story
you've never told me I don't know I'm
sure I have so many of them I'm tired of
talking about okay all right all right
okay through the first eight hundred and
ten games of his career Kevin Durant was
ejected just twice through the first 18
games of this season he's been kicked
out three times
what's going on with Kevin Durant reg is
going on with Kevin Durant I think if
you look along the landscape of the
league
maybe the officials are getting tired of
all the complaining I'm surprised at
that number when you couple who he plays
with draymond Green that's almost like a
regular occurrence yeah technicals and
getting thrown out so I look at him
being more aggressive at the defensive
end and you're on the number one team in
the league and all eyes are on you could
be a little bit of frustration but I
don't take anything out of him being
ejected this year or the aggressiveness
that he's showing defensively I kind of
like it he seems a little overly
sensitive
he still sort of doesn't understand that
people aren't going to embrace him the
way they embraced him in Oklahoma City
that he I I mean he just needs to move
on because people have their minds made
up it's like LeBron going to Miami even
though he came back to Cleveland to win
a championship people still have a
problem of how he left Cleveland in the
first place Kevin Durant just got to
move on and embrace the fact that
they're villains now in the NBA and
certainly he is too but winning will
help that
louboutin situation with KD look people
have source especially in a small market
people have long memories and the simple
fact that you didn't call your homeboy
or your so-called homeboy and Russell
Westbrook people have a problem with
that and to leave a team that was up 3-1
versus them and go to the team that have
the best record at 73 and nine people
shake their head
people think it's the easy way but I
think winning championships will make
people forget about that
that's bottom line for Kady don't worry
about what people think what people
tweet what people say on Instagram move
on win championships and that will shut
everyone up but if I look at that
situation reg did did we overstate the
friendship of Durant and Westbrook that
that he would not like it can you
imagine leaving and not calling or
letting your best friend know or best
teammate know I don't know if they're
friends but it did we overinflate their
friendship in Oklahoma City it seems
that we did you thought that they would
be better than that a simple phone call
would have done but again we don't know
the internal workings of what was going
on in that Thunder locker room we
thought they were closer than that yeah
but apparently they weren't and when you
see them play against one another and
you see the John and you know going
head-butting each other I like it
personally I like rivalries you don't
have to like someone to play with or
against them so I kind of like it
everyone happened everyone doesn't have
to high-five and hug it out before a
game there's okay with fist bumping and
let's play and let's talk a little trash
and but I get it I still have to get I
have to at least say hey I'm leaving I
just want you to know before anybody
else knows and I can't wait to come at
you I'm fine with that
I'm fine that once they get on the floor
they don't like each other but I got it
I have to add a respect give you a heads
up here
and I thought that Durant I don't care
if you don't like so how long do you
have to hold this garage I mean what if
what if KD has tried to reach out now is
it too late now reach out yes yes this
is how long do you hold a grudge forever
if I'm Westbrook I hold on to it forever
I have no problem with that yeah I mean
I would yeah I mean when Keith Oberman
left Sports Center
now this is the only way I can I can
make a reference to it but Keith at
least told me he was going to [ __ ] and I
said bring your lunch and bring your
dinner because I'm gonna bring it every
single night we're gonna cry and I and
that was my approach loved working with
him best teammate I ever had but he at
least told me I'm going to Fox and my
response was you better bring it because
I'm bringing it every single night let
me ask you a question - today are you
guys cool yeah we call you up we're fine
or yes well we're fine we weren't
friends we we got along great but
outside of work we weren't friends and
then he's gone into other things in
politics and I stayed in this business
so we don't cross paths but when we were
there I would have done anything for him
and when he left to go to Fox I wanted
to crush him looking at the relationship
between KD and Russ and I'm just a
simple basketball player now broadcast
analysts looking at the relationship and
looking at that last game it does look
like KD is trying to mend the fence and
Russell doesn't have anything to do I
wouldn't it can't
by the way you got Lakers at the 76ers
on Thursday night Wow what do you thin a
bigger picture here I know that people
have talked about LeBron and what he
joined this team and I certainly
understand that
how would LeBron fit in on the 76ers
with the current makeup of that team
LeBron would fit in with just about any
team because he's having that type of
year and he's that type of player so I
think he was fit in just fine I think
who would be effective would probably be
Ben Simmons yeah he's a lot like LeBron
James but LeBron in my opinion lavrov's
not going anywhere he's gonna stay in
Cleveland but absolutely I do I think
he's going to stay there and I think
they're gonna build around there I just
don't
where's he gonna go
I mean he's seen what's going on there
would you go to the Lakers or 76ers if I
if you were LeBron those were the two
options
aside from solutely I would I would say
in the east that I would then go to
Philadelphia but that affects Ben
Simmons growth and Ben Simmons is the
future in my opinion the future of that
team because he's an everyday player do
you think he's better than Joe LMB I
wouldn't say he's better more talent is
Joe and B but mbita's not an everyday
player until he becomes an everyday
player it's hard for me to judge that
you know you know he loads management
what that I learned something new every
day missing a game because of load
management are you serious my talent I
don't want that me love I love that he
doesn't like other sinners and I love
that he talks no I love everything about
Joe Ellen being other than he can't play
back-to-back games or four games in five
nights or three games in five nights
that's the only thing I don't like about
play you know okay if I gave you an MVP
vote right now Kyrie or LeBron or
somebody else or James Harden yeah
you're right yeah you're right you're
right Jay let me take James hard now
because as I told you earlier we want to
give the Greek freak the MVP and I mean
you guys are crazy
no no no he's in now the first two weeks
three weeks yes I would go with the
Greek three but there's there's other
challenge that has caught up if I had to
give an MVP right now yeah I mean it's
really hard to do miss what James Harden
is doing James Harden only plays one
half of the court and I at times he does
play great defense it is getting better
I would have to go with LeBron James I
love what Kyrie has done Kyrie has been
fantastic 1a would be LeBron one B would
be Kyrie then I would go with James
Harden then I would go with the Greek
freak Reggie will be on the call this
Thursday night for the Lakers and the
76ers 8:00 Eastern on TNT how about that
we made it all the way through and we
didn't talk about you know who of the
Lakers or his dad
I will say this about top of all I don't
agree with anything that comes out of
his mouth
I really don't but to label him the
worst dad ever to me I think it's
disrespectful because I think he does a
lot for his sons is he capitalizing on
his sons and his family absolutely
but there's a lot of dads that don't
want anything to do with their kids and
he's not one of them so I can't call him
the worst day no he's not just wish I
wish he would just do things differently
and I wish he would say things can't to
help promote his sons as opposed to
putting targets on their backs that's my
personal look but now I'm taking him out
of college now he's you know preparing
them preparing them from the NBA jello
ball will not be playing next year the
NBA and China will have fun on Thursday
night and we'll be watching wrench thank
you that's Reggie Aloysius Miller for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]